est ce que ça vous dirait devenir
personnalisées directement l'écran
d'accueil de votre iphone ça on peut le
faire grâce à un os 16 et je vous montre
comment ça marche soit votre écran
d'accueil voulait s'appuyer et vous
pouvez venir en rajouter très facilement
sur le côté en appuyant son petit plus
on se prend une photo hazard pourrait
venir choisir l'aspect global en
modulant comme ça par exemple vous
appuyez sur les trois petits points
droite ou émettent loki ça va venir au
fond c'est l'arrière plan ensuite vous
ajouter des widgets vous pouvez avoir
une lune comme ça ou encore la météo la
batterie votre activité ou bien encore
votre pourcentage de batterie et votre
agenda et une fois que vous
déverrouillez votre iphone et bien vous
pouvez venir tout est votre photo ou la
laisser